me
good afternoon everyone and i'm pleased
to be here to provide an update on the
safe return to school for alberta
students
last week we extended the winter break
by one week to allow school authorities
time to plan in the face of the rapid
search of the omicron variant
understandably school
staff absences not only for teachers but
also for the many other albertans who
support our students such as bus drivers
teaching assistants support staff and
administration
over the past several days my team and i
have continued to work closely with
school authorities
i'm extremely grateful for their input
and i'm so pleased to confirm that ecs
and kindergarten to grade 12 students
will return two classrooms on january
10th
children who learn in person belong in
the classroom and they will be there
with the added safety of rapid tests and
medical grade masks
these will be distributed to schools as
an added layer of protection to lower
the risk of transmission of the omicron
variant
the government will begin distributing
shipments of rapid tests and masks later
this week
and all schools will have their initial
shipments by the end of next week
distribution to students and staff will
occur as individual schools receive
their supplies
and both rapid tests and masks will be
shipped in phases
this is on top of the many significant
health measures schools already have in
place
such as vaccine vaccine policies for
staff
masking
distancing and enhanced cleaning
measures
in making this decision we looked very
carefully at information from school
authorities as well as health data
we also considered other jurisdictions
in canada who are doing similar things
such as bc and manitoba
i also want to point out that many other
places around the world have been
committed to keeping schools open for
in-class instruction with additional
measures in place
take new york city for example where
students spent last year learning online
instead of in person
this year they are very determined to
remain in the classroom despite the
omicron variant surge
experts across canada and around the
world continue to stress the importance
of in-person learning to the overall
health of our children and our youth
and i myself have had have heard
overwhelmingly from families that
learning in person is best for children
most children feel more connected they
learn better and generally thrive when
they are at school in person
this is why alberta's government has
placed such a high priority on safe in
classroom instruction and on making sure
that our schools have the tools that
they need
it's why we've invested more than one
billion dollars in taxpayer funding to
help schools deal with covet uh 19 which
includes 130 million dollars in coveted
mitigation funding for the 2122 school
year
we've also allowed school authorities to
access taxpayer-funded reserves
including operating reserves which have
grown to
464 million dollars an increase of more
than 80 million dollars since the
since pardon me the pandemic began
this is overall
school board operating in capital
reserves currently sitting at over 700
million dollars
again
school board operating in capital
reserves sitting at over 700 million
dollars
additionally as students return to the
class we're helping them get back on
track
students in grades four to nine and
their parents will now be able to access
free online tutoring resources starting
next week
this will help them catch up on
important skills and learn
and learning that they may have fallen
behind on during the pandemic
the e-tutoring hub will be launched with
pre-recorded video tutoring sessions on
literacy and numeracy that students and
their parents can access anytime
and later this year online tutoring will
be expanded to include more subjects and
grades and live tutoring will be offered
parents students and educators are
encouraged to try the tool and give us
feedback to inform future sessions
it's another crucial step to help
students close the gap on pandemic
learning and it builds on our investment
of up to 45 million dollars to address
covet related learning disruptions for
students in grades one to three
finally alberta education is continuing
to work closely with school authorities
to support shifts that may be required
for operational reasons such as student
or staff absences
school authorities will continue to have
the flexibility to shift an individual
class or grade to short-term at-home
learning if needed
while decisions on shifting an entire
school or school authority to at-home
learning will continue to be approved by
the government
decisions will be made quickly and
consideration will always be given to
absenteeism rates and other relevant
data including local health data if it
is available
again i'd like to thank everyone in
alberta's education system who is
continuing to prepare for the safe
return of our students to the classroom
next monday january 10th
and as i've said before i'm always so
impressed by the resilience shown by our
students our staff our school boards and
our families in the whole education
system kudos to all of them
and to the students and everyone who
cares for them thank you for your hard
work and perseverance during two very
tough years
and to the teachers and school staff
thank you for continuing to deliver the
world-class education alberta is known
for now i will turn it over to dr
hinshaw for her update
thank you minister and good afternoon
everyone
over the last 24 hours we have
identified about 4752
new cases of covid19 and completed about
12 000 tests
our positivity rate for lab confirmed
cases is 36.9 percent
both of these numbers bring us to new
record daily highs underlining the
impact of this wave
there are currently 470 people with
covet 19 in hospital including 72 in the
icu
sadly i must announce that 11 new deaths
have been reported to alberta health
over the last 24 hours my thoughts and
sympathies are with the family and
friends left behind to mourn these
people
and anyone who has recently lost a loved
one from any cause
i know the rampant spread of omicron has
made this a challenging start to 2022
for many albertans including parents
children teachers school staff and
administrators who are all working to do
what's best for children in alberta
once again the shifting nature of the
virus required us all to pause and
re-evaluate the best path forward for
the second half of the school year
we all know the impacts that being away
from the classroom can have on our
children's mental health learning and
social interaction
we know that covet infection has a low
but not zero risk for children
we also know that in person learning is
critically important for many kids
educational and social development and
can provide a sense of stability and
normalcy in these challenging times
there are no perfect completely risk
free solutions available to us
or any jurisdiction around the world
and i believe the provincial approach
balances the many competing risks that
our children face
the use of rapid testing and medical
masks in addition to the measures
already in place
will help to protect students and staff
as they return to the classroom
given the current situation i also want
to note that i strongly recommend that
students in all grades wear masks
including kindergarten to grade three
to keep the risk in schools low it will
be in critical for all of us to stay
home and keep our children home if any
of us have symptoms
i want to remind albertans that we're in
a very different situation today than we
were when school started the past fall
this past fall or the year before
that's thanks to widely available safe
effective vaccines and the thousands of
staff and students who've been immunized
for covet 19.
now all children 5 years and older are
eligible to be vaccinated against
covid19
approximately 85 percent of youth
between the ages of 12 and 17 have
received at least one vaccine dose and
around 80 percent have received two
while children between 5 and 11 have
only been eligible for vaccines since
late november 37 have already received
at least one dose of vaccine
if your child hasn't been vaccinated
against covid19 yet
i strongly recommend doing so as soon as
possible
it is the single most effective tool we
have to reduce the risk of infection and
severe illness from the virus
a recent publication from the u.s cdc
affirmed the safety of vaccine and 5 to
11 year olds looking at 8.7 million
doses of vaccine and identifying any
significant adverse events such as fever
and severe vomiting happening after only
0.001 percent of all doses
as parents our first priority is always
the safety and well-being of our
children and i understand the need to
make the best data informed decision for
them
if you have questions about the vaccine
or would like more information please
reach out to a medical professional to
get answers
you can talk to your family doctor or
pediatrician call 8-1-1 or listen to the
pediatric vaccine town hall recording
that's posted on alberta.ca
since march of 2020 children of all ages
have sacrificed a lot to keep others
safe
this was especially true in the early
months of the pandemic when they missed
out on in-person learning
extracurricular activities and time
spent simply being kids
now that we know more about preventing
transmission and we have safe effective
vaccines available to everyone age five
and older
i believe it is prudent to keep schools
open for in-person instruction
however we all have a role to play in
helping to keep schools open and
children safe by limiting community
transmission
next to getting vaccinated the most
critical thing we can do is stay home if
we're sick
especially
even with the mildest of symptoms
wearing masks and keeping our distance
at all times also reduces our risks of
spreading the virus
but they cannot eliminate all risks of
exposure this is especially true with
the highly transmissible omicron variant
each day parents must complete a health
assessment of their children to see if
there are any signs of illness
and should do a rapid test a couple of
times a week to screen for asymptomatic
infection and limit the risk of
introducing infection into schools
these steps are critical to limiting
exposure in schools and keeping them
open
as a parent i want to say that i
understand the mixed emotions that many
families may be feeling with today's
announcement
as students return to the classroom next
week including my own i know some
parents will be relieved that their kids
will get to see their friends and
teachers in person again at the same
time they may be worried about their
children's health and well-being or have
anxiety over the uncertainties of the
new variant
every family needs to make the right
decision for their own situations
knowing that community transmission will
continue to be high over at least the
next month
the current approach balances the risks
all our children face
and each family will need to weigh the
impacts of those risks for them
finally given the changes we've made to
our testing protocols and contact
notification process in light of the
omicron variant
i also want to advise albertans that we
will be moving to a different approach
for school reporting that reflects the
current situation
similar to other provinces with the
growth of covid19 cases alberta is now
focused on investigating cases in high
risk settings such as continuing care
and those who work in healthcare
other cases including in students and
school staff
will still be notified of their own test
result and they will receive a call to
ensure they're aware of their isolation
requirements
but ahs will no longer have the capacity
to do full case investigations for those
non-high-risk cases
as a result of this change and similar
to other provinces alberta is assessing
different options for an approach to
school reporting that reflects the
current situation
details on this will be shared as soon
as they are available
there are no easy paths to take in a
pandemic but as has always been critical
we must do our best to look at the whole
health of our communities our families
and our children thank you and we're
happy to take questions
thank you dr hinshaw and mr lagrange we
are now going to the phone lines to
answer a few questions from media
everyone in the queue will get an
opportunity to ask a question and have a
follow-up question
i ask that you please identify yourself
and what media outlet you represent and
who your question is for operator please
put through the first caller
thank you the first question is from
jeremy thompson ctv
hi there a question for i believe the
education minister um
lots of questions from uh from parents
and teachers still about uh you know air
quality in in schools
some folks running into issues you know
have fun they fundraise to
buy their own hepa filter and then
bureaucracy gets in the way from them
actually getting it into the classroom
so wondering what uh what's being done
to ensure air quality can be monitored
and maybe improved and any associated
funding with that
well thank you for the question and uh
air quality has always been a concern
from the start of the pandemic that's
why we allocated as a province 250
million dollars towards capital
maintenance and renewal funding
accelerated capital maintenance and
renewal funding for school boards to
access many of that funding was used by
school boards to upgrade hvac and
improve their systems
i know that the cmoh
and dr henshaw may want to add
once i'm finished speaking here to my
comments
that their recommendation is to make
sure that the ventilation systems that
are in place are in good working order
all our school authorities have made
that their highest priority and i know
they are continuing to look at what
improvements can be made should there be
any required now additionally i know
that uh stand-alone help to filter
you know systems that can be placed into
account classroom unless they're
the overall system is looked at by
experts sometimes that actually can be
more of a hindrance than
than an improvement to the system so
again
looking to see what can be done but
school authorities have have made this
their top priority and they continue to
work on further refinements if necessary
dr hincho would you like to add anything
no she's saying that
my answer was sufficient thank you for
that and jeremy do you have a follow-up
question
i i do and uh you know either the
minister or dr hincha could answer this
one and basically wondering you know
with with the change to
reporting and tracking cases in schools
you know can you just kind of walk me
through
what will happen now once you know it's
someone test positive or you know i
guess is it different for a student and
a teacher
well
obviously we will continue to
as dr hinchell said that if there
are people with symptoms whether it's a
student or a teacher or a staff member
they should stay home
and take a rapid test
and
if that turns out to be positive
they should report it to the school
we will then
look at the school authorities
themselves will track absenteeism
from a general perspective we are
looking to refine the actual numbers
that school authorities would be looking
at
if there's high absenteeism whether it's
students or staff
as well as
spread within the community et cetera
all of those factors would be taken into
account from a school authority
perspective they would look at do we
need to shift or do they need to shift a
classroom or a grade to online learning
if it's required because of high
absenteeism and other health
indicators within their schools if not
they would continue on provide the subs
etcetera if in fact there are larger
numbers then we would look to
to to them to approve those shifts and
if there are even larger numbers
affecting a school or a whole school
authority then they would approach my
department and we would have the
conversations on if there's a shift
required for a larger group of
individuals
thank you minister operator can you put
through the next caller
dr devo radio canada
hi there my question is for dr henshaw
um you said yourself that the positive
positivity rate is much higher in the
transmissibility is also
so
how can you be so sure that children
still are at low risk of infection and
transmission
the
community transmission risk right now is
the highest it's ever been so i want to
be clear that out in the general
community no matter what the setting
there is a very high transmission risk
right now and i continue to advise that
people do everything they can to
minimize the number of close contacts
they have however i also believe that if
we were to
shut schools across the entire province
we would be
imposing much greater harm on all of
those students by
not allowing them the opportunity for
in-school learning at this time we have
additional measures that are in place
with respect to the regular rapid
testing that's available medical mass
use
and so i believe that the the ability to
then
monitor and intervene if there are
significant local risks and some of the
ways that minister lagrange has just
mentioned
would be the best balance because we
know that again there is a significant
risk of harm to kids
by keeping them home for long periods of
time and so returning to school in
person gives the opportunity to adjust
and
focus on where there are specific local
issues rather than making that decision
preemptively for the entire province
thank you dr hinshaw and for your
follow-up question
uh yes i'm not entirely sure understood
what you said about the online learning
portion so my apologies but um isn't
there a way to put maybe one or two
weeks of online learning to kind of act
as a buffer before going back in person
for those children
there's always options uh looking at
again universal online learning versus
universal in-person learning we know
that
kids have had
different experiences over the past
couple of years we've tried to keep
schools open
however there have been times when
they've had to shift the challenge that
we're facing right now
as we look ahead is that
we wouldn't know
necessarily what length of time would
that be and again to just close schools
across the entire province as opposed to
allowing opportunities to return and
then using interventions where they're
appropriate in terms of targeted areas
is the in my opinion best balance of the
benefits to kids of being able to be
present in school and where there is
significant transmission in a local area
then there can be movement online in
that particular local area where it's
needed
we know that kids have had a significant
toll on their mental health
on their development over the past two
years and so every
incremental loss of in-person school
time
adds up and so this is this has a
different consequence than spending a
few weeks online early in the pandemic
this is coming at a time where there is
again that heavy heavy burden of the
mental health and the challenges that
kids have faced throughout the pandemic
and we need to look at that whole health
of our kids
thank you dr hinshaw operator can you
put through the next caller
wyatt sharp the wyatt sharp show
uh hi there i'm just going to ask um for
the education minister you mentioned
other jurisdictions are keeping their
schools opened i believe you mentioned
new york city as an example however a
lot of provinces in canada have
decided to delay it longer than alberta
nova scotia just recently announced that
they're delaying it until january the
17th um the case positivity rate in
alberta is actually higher than it was
in ontario today ontario's was 28.1
and ontario's decided to delay it by two
weeks so i'm just wondering how alberta
will look at other jurisdictions in the
future when making decisions as to
whether or not to keep schools open
great question wyatt and thank you for
that
so we look at it in and of course
looking to balance the best interest of
alberta students
but also looking to see what other
provinces are doing we know that ontario
has taken a different course but they're
at a different stage in the omicron
variant
transmissibility
across the province we look at the fact
that our hospitalization numbers and our
and our
icu numbers continue to to stay
you know relatively low at this point in
time
we feel that at this point in time we
are ready to go back we've had the
additional one week spoken to school
divisions i had a meeting with all the
school boards and superintendents this
morning
school board chairs and
feeling very strongly that they're ready
uh given the extra time that they've had
to make sure that they're prepared as dr
hinshaw indicated
there is higher transmissibility that
will come into our our schools and into
our classrooms but we need to mitigate
that with the overall health of our
children uh which is ultimately
important and i just want to highlight
that our schools were safe before the
pandemic they were safe the last two
years during the pandemic with all of
the measures that we put in place with
these additional measures they will
continue to be safe
thank you minister and why do you have a
follow-up question
i do yeah um so just on the
hospitalizations part so
as you did point out ontario does have a
significantly higher number
of hospitalizations
their hospitalizations today was 2081
and i believe you meant uh dr hinchey
mentioned that alberta's was only 470
but when you look at the population of
ontario and the population of alberta
obviously ontario's postulation is over
three times
the population of alberta so would you
not expect ontario's hospitalized
hospitalization rate to be that much
higher than it is in alberta
on a per capita basis
but when we look at
the fact that
alberta continues
you know not to have the
spike that ontario has
ontario is in a different situation than
we are they've made different decisions
all along
last year they had their students out
right till the end of the school year
they only return to in-person learning
in september so i you know as much as we
look to them they have different
circumstances if dr hinchey would like
to speak to this
she certainly is welcome to on the
hospitalization and rates and numbers
but
i will
i'll turn it over to dr hinshaw
we know that hospitalizations are a
lagging indicator so
we will be watching that closely as
ontario is slightly ahead of us in the
omicron curve
again we know that there are no zero
risk options there never have been and
we need to consider that whole health of
our students as we consider that
province-wide option knowing that we
still have that ability to
use local mitigation measures where
we're seeing a particular surge
and knowing that kids have had the
burden of being online learning
significant numbers of times over the
last year even though we've tried to
keep it minimal so again this is giving
us that ability to
use local and targeted measures where
they're most appropriate rather than
depriving all students across the
province of the opportunity to return to
in-class learning
thank you dr hinshaw operator can you
put through the next caller
david staples edmonton journal
all right uh this is for uh dr hinshaw
and i guess the minister
the minister just said that schools have
been saved throughout and i'm just
wondering if if we can look at um
there's been various states of uh
uh
covid you know where where people were
unvaccinated before
um it's been uh seems like a more deadly
disease under the delta as it compared
to the omicron so how safe now in terms
of
ranking the safety how safe in the next
month will schools be in alberta as
compared to at the start of the pandemic
or when when uh we had uh
delta last spring and this and this fall
how safe relatively are the schools
compared to before
we know with our
approach previously in school we
typically if we did see in school
transmission it was to a small number of
people
there were rare instances where
there were larger outbreaks but for the
most part transmission was maintained to
a very small number of people
bc has done a very robust evaluation
that
has been
put out publicly that indicates that the
average number of people who acquired
infection if there were if there was an
in-school transmission was about two
which included that that delta and again
we used very similar mitigation measures
in our classrooms to british columbia
so we've seen throughout the pandemic
that while the risk of introduction into
a school is higher when there's high
community risk the actual school
environment continues to be one where
there is a limited risk of onward spread
again not zero but we've kept it minimal
with omicron the risk of transmission in
the community is definitely higher which
is why there's additional mitigating
measures that have been put in place
into schools
however the individual risk of omicron
in terms of severity does seem to be
lower so with respect to the school
environment
my assessment would be that it's
relatively similar to what we saw
previously where
even though omicron is a more
transmissible virus we have additional
mitigation measures in place at this
point in time and that individual risk
of severity is lower and given the very
significant benefit that schools provide
both at an individual and a population
level again
it is my belief that we should do
everything we can to keep schools open
even as we strive to keep community
spread lower by use of other tools
thank you dr henshaw david do you have a
follow-up question
yes
i believe that last
may when schools went online for a time
i believe it was then that the driver of
that was teachers um
getting sick with kovid and not having
enough teachers and substitute teachers
keeping keep things running and i'm
wondering with the high transmissibility
of the omicron
is there any consideration to having
teachers i i mean they might be declared
essential workers already
and you've talked about that already
could teachers be seen as essential
workers who can go to work if they have
a positive test but are asymptomatic and
not showing any any science is that
under consideration to keep the schools
open
well certainly at this point in time
we're looking to
access all of the sub substitute
teachers that we have available when
they're when they're needed
we would look to other mitigating
factors first
should that be required we can look at
it at a later point but at this point in
time that's not being considered
thank you minister operator can you put
through the next caller
lauren pullen global calgary
hi there thanks for taking my question
this afternoon the first one is for the
minister and actually uh follow up on
that staffing question we have heard
from a local school division that the
number of teachers with coveted 19 has
increased dramatically over the winter
break of course we've seen omicron
transmission increase dramatically and
short staffing has previously of course
been one of the reasons for schools
needing to shift online can you quantify
what the ministry has heard from school
divisions about staffing levels for the
january 10th reopening and maybe get us
through what the staffing plan is so
that we don't wind up in a yoyo type
effect here in two or three weeks
possibly having to shift online
so every school authority is responsible
for their own staffing so each one will
look different
you know different jurisdictions have
access to different numbers of
substitute teachers educational supports
etc
so it will look different across the
province what i'm hearing what i heard
from school divisions this morning was
that they have been making plans they've
been utilizing this week to to enhance
their cleaning protocols to make sure
that they are able to to look at what
might be coming in next week
in terms of staff shortages if there are
any
right now there i've heard as you know
that there were
some school divisions that
had early absences of around five
percent i also want to remind everyone
that now with omicron that the isolation
period after testing positive with
omicron is five days so that will affect
also how quickly students and staff
members can get back into the classroom
so there's many factors to look at we
are continuing to monitor it very
closely and we'll work with school
divisions
to help them
navigate through this very and it'll be
tricky i'm not saying it'll be easy but
it we certainly will help them navigate
through these uh interesting times
thank you minister caller do you have a
follow-up question
i do thank you and this one is uh for
both the minister and dr hinshaw
minister you said that you looked at
health data in making this decision can
you specifically point to and explain
what that data was what it showed and uh
will it be publicly released so that
everyone can take a look at it well we
looked at health data from across the
province as well as what the health data
is telling us in terms of the effects of
prolonged online learning
or out of the classroom learning for
students and the detrimental effects
there's numerous data across
not only canada but across the world
that is highlighting that and we will
certainly
share that data as
you know as we are able to
um dr hinch i'm not sure if there's
anything you would like to further add
to this
um she's not indicating that there's
anything further she'd like to add
thank you minister we have time for one
more round of questions operator can you
put through the last caller
sarah comedina global news
hi thank you for taking my question when
it comes to the supplies that are going
to be sent with rapid test kits and
other ppe that are being sent to the
schools uh
do you expect
them at all to be delivered on january
10th i know you mentioned the phases
that will schools have enough supplies
on january 10th
so we had school authorities get back to
us by late day monday with specific
numbers on sizes of masks because of
course we will need pediatric masks for
younger students
as well as adult size masks and
they have returned that information to
us we're working very closely with ahs
and municipal affairs to stage that
that delivery
to schools some school authorities have
preferred that the deliveries go
directly to the schools others have
preferred that it goes to a central
location and they will take care of
dispersing it so we are certainly
respecting school authorities wishes in
that regard we anticipate that masks and
rapid tests will be going out the door
and to school authorities by the end of
this week with all deliveries to school
authorities the initial deliveries by
next week and then further phasing after
that of course we are going to supply
them over the course of january and into
february so we're going to continue
those supplies uh to ensure that they
have the proper amounts that they
require
thank you minister and do you have a
follow-up question
yes um a big part of today's
announcement was the online tutoring
that's going to be offered i mean with
that
what have we seen with students when it
comes to
um their grades and their reading levels
and math skills and all of that because
of online learning how like did many
students suffer or fall behind
what we're hearing
is that we are hearing from school
authorities that there has been some
some learning loss during the periods of
disruption that have occurred over the
last
year and a half two years um certainly
uh school authorities are are mitigating
that as best they can but this is an
additional support for our students and
for their families something that they
can access during their home times for
additional help something that teachers
can tap into again as an additional tool
to help them through that
that process teachers have been doing an
amazing job under very difficult
circumstances so i want to again thank
our teachers and our teaching community
for all of the great work that they've
been doing under some really stressful
times and so i thank them for the great
work that they're doing this is just an
additional support for that um the
possible learning loss that has occurred
thank you minister and with that that is
all the time that we have today so we're
going to wrap this up thank you
everybody thank you
you